bienvenue dans africo n'être reportée
d'un an pandémie oblige au moment où
nous enregistrons à cette émission le
doute plane encore sur la tenue de la
can 2022 au cameroun en raison de la
crise sanitaire une première décision de
la maintenir est intervenue le 9
décembre à un mois du coup d'envoi de la
pluie suivi des compétitions sur le
continent une canne qui en dehors des
terrains de football n'échappe pas à son
lot de couacs et d'incertitude la can
2022 encore un casse-tête africains on
en parle tout de suite avec nos invités
on se connecte avec ta nou diallo
experts médias la confédération
africaine de football la caf en charge
de l'organisation et patrick baumann
ancien international camerounais
vainqueur de la can avec les lions
indomptables
en 2000 il interviendra tout au long de
l'émission via un enregistrement
bonjour thanou diallo merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans afrique
connect bonjour sans mandat et c'est un
plaisir
alors en raison de cette pandémie les
nombreux clubs européens ont décidé de
passer à l'action l association
européenne des clubs menacent de ne pas
libérer ses joueurs et selon nos
confrères d'rmc et bien la caf
réfléchirai à annuler la compétition
quelles sont vos informations alors c
c'est clairement une fake news ça jamais
été discuté et ça n'a jamais été
envisagé d'annuler ou de délocaliser la
coupe d'afrique des nations de football
aujourd'hui en afrique
cette campagne médiatique est vu comme
un comme un sabotage de la part de
certains médias européens
par rapport à l'organisation de la coupe
d'afrique des nations il faut dire que
la can c'est la compétition la plus
prestigieuse du continent tout le monde
attend c'est cette compétition et quand
on a entendu ces informations ont été
assez surpris mais en même temps on a vu
que avant que cette information ne soit
diffusée il ya eu un communiqué de
l'association des clubs de football
européens
qui menacent et de ne pas libérer les
stars africaines pour aller à cette
coupe d'afrique des nations par rapport
à la situation sanitaire et et c'est que
ces gens oublient c'est que l'afrique
est moins impactés
par rapport à l'europe quand on parle du
de lakovic 19 le drame que ce vu sa
cause en europe il ya jamais eu ça avait
aujourd'hui les gens ne sont pas du tout
contents sous le continent parce que
c'est la revue tout simplement comme
comme un sabotage comme un sabotage et
et c'est inacceptable pour pour tout le
monde on ne veut pas du tout quand on ne
veut pas priver les africains de leur de
leur compétition phare et la can va se
jouer au cameroun et elle débute le 9
janvier au stade roland b je voulais que
l'on commence par à écouter cette
réaction de l'ex international
camerounais patrick mboma par action
j'ai passé la compétition va finalement
se tenir au cab ont rejeté au cameroun
et j'ai vu les sites ou de novembre et
j'étais plutôt séduit et impressionné
malheureusement impressionné parce que
j'aurais voulu que l'état dans lequel et
on a trop on a trouvé les
infrastructures puisse être ce même état
depuis deux trois décennies mais peu
importe on a de très belles
infrastructures sportives
voilà de la confiance affichée de la
part de patrick m'boma mais du
soulagement aussi comme on l'imaginait
chez la plupart de ses compatriotes en
2019 le cameroun a dû renoncer à
l'organisation de la compétition en
raison de retards au niveau des
infrastructures mais là qu'est ce qui a
motivé finalement la décision de la caf
renoncer je ne pense pas que ça soit le
monde le monde juste c'est juste la caf
à ce moment là j'ai trouvé que le
cameroun n'était pas prêt pour abriter
la coupe d'afrique des nations c'est en
ce moment qu'elle a depuis qu'elle a
lancé un appel d'offres et puis il ya eu
deux pays qui se sentent des candidats
je vais m'organiser
c'était l'egypte et l'afrique dans le
voir là le comité exécutif de la caf et
a eu un enfant et c'est l'egypte qui a
obtenu dans l'action de la can 2019 du
coup voilà cette fois ci il ya eu à ce
moment-là à cette décision a été prise
il ya eu un glissement on s'est dit
qu'en local on a fait beaucoup
d'investissements
du coup vu que ce pays n'est pas prêt
2019 on vend la corde et la prochaine
can c'était la can 2025 comme vous
l'avez dit tout de suite vous l'avez
rappelé et il ya eu cette situation
sanitaire de covit donc lui dans le
monde là quand la pub n'a pas pu avoir
lieu en 2021 finalement c'est un 2022
et voilà elle se glisse - dont je parle
de tout de suite du sud la côte d'ivoire
organisé la can 2023 et la guinée la
cale de
5h à cannes des questions des
incertitudes les africains retiennent
leur souffle ya des problèmes
d'organisation
d'accueil de retard aussi des
infrastructures tout le monde se demande
si cette can elle va bien se dérouler où
elle sera reportée ce que c'est une
sorte finalement de tradition on peut
dire les choses ainsi où ça reflète
réellement à les difficultés d'un
football africain qui est pourtant
pourvoyeur de talents
quand vous le savez depuis il ya eu une
élection la tête de la côte
17 à marmande le mag a succédé à issa
hayatou à ce moment-là lui pendant sa
campagne il avait promis de faire passer
la can de 16 à 24 équipes donc du coup
il a été élu dès qu'il a été élu il a
fait passer cette réforme le cameroun
qui avait obtenu la nation de 2009 à
2014 devait organiser une can à ses
équipes donc finalement elle a le
cameroun était obligé à
ses équipes avec quatre stades vous
pouvez organiser la compétition
maintenant que quand on passe avec
quatre équipes il faudrait avoir six
stades six stades de compétition avec
tous les terrains d'entraînement qui
autour donc c'est ce qui fait que
certainement les camerounais ont eu
beaucoup de difficultés à ce niveau-là
ce même si c'est pas une excuse nous et
ce après ça explique aussi peut-être le
retard d'un d'un à l'organisation de la
can dont il dans ce pays la cité pas que
si vous vous rappelez
de la can en janvier
2019 en six mois l'egypte était prêt
pour acquérir 4 pour la première fois
une canne vingt quatre équipes avant
cela on se remet tait ou on était au
gabon 2010 est à mon avis il n'y a pas
eu de problème c'est en 2015
normalement laquelle devait avoir lieu
dans notre pays que ce pays n'était pas
prêt finalement c'est la guinée
équatoriale qui a accueilli la coupe
d'afrique des nations est-ce qu'à tout
moment il ya des problèmes oui mais des
problèmes mineurs on avait il faut pas
en faire des tonnes c'est vrai que
veulent pas le moment a eu parfois il ya
des problèmes mais aux finances on finit
toujours par problème alors justement on
va écouter cette réaction de patrick
mboma justement qui lui restent
optimistes comme vous et on va en parler
on écoute je resterai le footballeur
dans l'âme puisque plus qu'un politicien
que je ne suis pas et que je ne souhaite
pas nécessairement devenir donc
quand j'ai dit que comme on n'était pas
un bon élève c'est parce que la can ne
s'est pas disputé en 2019 mais c'est
disputera bien en 2022 cette can 2021 et
j'aimerais aussi à l'avenir voir si la
carte sera aussi exigeante avec les
futures
pépites est l'un des pays qui vont à
l'avenir accueillir des prochaines
coupes d'afrique des nations le cameroun
est un grand pays de football parlons
quand même le pays le cameroun est un
grand pays de football aujourd'hui il ya
huit stades à même de répondre aux
exigences
de la caf il ya six stades capables de
répondre aux exigences de la fifa c'est
à dire deux stades coupe du monde
ensuite on a fait de gros efforts au
niveau des infrastructures
hôtelières on a fait le gouvernement a
consenti de gros efforts sur nos
hôpitaux notamment nous sommes de santé
ça ce sont déjà des victoires pour pour
le cameroun bien sûr ça a peut-être
coûté cher voire trop cher mais je
préfère garder le positif et ne pas me
mettre dans la tête de politiciens
qu'ils soient de l'opposition ou non
pour vous raconter ce qui ne va pas j'ai
envie de regarder ce qui va et je vous
le dis encore une fois savante à moi je
suis un sportif et le sportif est
content de voir que le cameroun jeu j'ai
envie de le promettre va offrir une
belle compétition allemand il ya quand
même du politique dans l'organisation
des caennais qui se succèdent notamment
celle au cameroun est ce que la caf
s'est montré trop exigeante vis-à-vis du
cameroun
il faut il rappeler quelque chose qui
est très important entre temps il ya eu
un changement à la tête de la
confédération africaine de football
c'est un nouveau président qui est l'un
sert nouveau ses côtés jacques ira c'est
une nouvelle administration qui s'est
mise en place donc ils ont leurs idées
ils ont leur façon de voir les choses et
ils ont ils veulent avoir une montre la
coupe d'afrique des nations parce que
pour eux il faut au cameroun il faut
avoir la meilleure lamure quand possible
donc si la caf a été exigeante à ce
niveau là ce n'est pas du tout pour
faire du mal au cameroun mais c'est pour
la voir l'objectif c'est d'avoir la
meilleure compétition aussi un bon est
ce que la caf pourrait contourner la
règle pour d'autres pays en raison
justement de diverses considérations
notamment financières
il faut dire clairement que ça va être
très très compliqué pour beaucoup de
pays africains d'organiser une à 24
équipes ça il faut il faut être clair là
dessus s'il faut des gros - c'est pas
tous les pays africains qui seront
désormais capables d'organiser une canne
à 24 équipes surtout beaucoup de pays au
sud du sahara pour les pays du nord il y
aura pas de problème pour l'afrique du
sud y aura pas de problème mais dans
beaucoup d'autres pays ça va être un
gros problème donc à ce niveau il faut
passer il faut pas se mentir
organiser une can à 24 équipes -
beaucoup de moins est ce que la can u20
est ce que la caf doit contourner cette
règle je ne pense pas parce que là où la
caf la caf fois essayé de mettre la
barre très haut donc si vous n'êtes
carte pas capable d'organiser une canne
à 24 équipes et plus nous ne sollicitez
pas l'organisation de cette compétition
pour cette can 2022 les yeux sont rivés
sur le fameux stade de limbé confronté à
des retards de travaux et un scandale
financier présumé on va écouter à ce
propos patrick m'boma
international camerounais si vous
m'aviez dit en
2014 qui est là qu'il allait y avoir
des extensions de fond de détournement
et que le stade coûterait plus cher que
les à-coups serait plus cher que s'ils
ne devaient je vous dirais que je ne
suis pas surpris maintenant je pense que
du côté de de l'opposition et c'est
logique j'irai même sans être de
l'opposition on peut se
dire qu'effectivement c'est pas très
sainte anne oudia nouilhan scandales
financiers à réelle ou pas autour de
justement de ce fameux stade de limbé
ça c'est à l'état comme rouler de
déterminer si un scandale financier ou
pas de l'état camerounais s'est endettée
auprès des banques pour a construit le
système si un scandale autour c'est à
l'état camerounais de faire de mener des
enquêtes et ici à des coûts peuple à
l'état camerounais de les sanctionner
donc ça c'est vraiment un problème un
problème qu'en monnaies qui doit être
gérée par les cambonnais donc ça ça ne à
ce niveau moi personnellement je ne peux
pas faire de commentaires là dessus mais
on parle quand même de l'un des plus
grands scandales financiers au cameroun
comment la caf a réagi face à cette
affaire
à ce niveau je suis pas je suis pas la
personne non autorisée pour enfin le
commentaire sur un sujet paraît moins
performants comme je vous ai dit
s'il y a effectivement eu scandale
financier c'est à l'état camerounais de
mener des enquêtes et d'identifier les
coupables et de les sanctionner thanou
diallou on va marquer une courte pause
et se retrouver dans un instant pour
poursuivre à rester avec nous sur arte
france on se retrouve dans un instant
pour la suite d'afrique connect
retour dans l'afrique connect nous
sommes avec ta nou diallo experts médias
à la confédération africaine de football
ont évoqué avec vous le fameux stade de
limbé baptisé stade omnisport paul biya
avec ses vrais autour de ce stade des
soupçons de scandales financiers le
cameroun on vous l'avait dit qu'il s'est
endetté à hauteur de 55 milliards de
francs cfa pour finaliser les travaux du
stade un stade qu'il n'était pas encore
livré à un mois du coup d'envoi de cette
can visites guidées tout de suite
le stade olympique et pourra-t-il être
livré à temps alors que la 33e coupe
d'afrique des nations doit se tenir au
cameroun du 15 janvier au 28 février
prochain le chantier du stade par paul
biya olembe n'est toujours pas finalisé
il faut dire que depuis le début de sa
construction il ya douze ans le stade
qui doit accueillir le match d'ouverture
de la can le 9 janvier connaît de
nombreuses déconvenues et a connu de
nombreuses entreprises pour la
réalisation du chantier un projet
titanesque une infrastructure de 60000
places une face à l'esthétisme singulier
symbolisant des écailles multicolores du
pangolin pour un coût estimé à plus de
200 milliards de francs cfa en 2010 9
l'entreprise canadienne maj il
promettait de reprendre le chantier pour
un achèvement des travaux en six mois
mais au mois d'août l'entreprise
délaisse le chantier abandonnant
fournisseurs et sous traitants les
infrastructures prévues aux alentours du
stade ne connaissent pas meilleur sort
des terrains d'entraînement centre
commercial route et hôtel 4 étoiles les
chantiers ne sont pas totalement
finalisé alors que la date butoir du
mois d'octobre 2020 avait été annoncé
pour les dernières finitions
déjà décalé d'un an pour cause de covile
19 la fifa menace aujourd'hui de ne plus
laisser partir certains joueurs pour
participer à la compétition
et même si des rumeurs d'une
délocalisation au qatar circule le
cameroun poursuit ses efforts et aucune
décision n'a officiellement confirmé la
tenue de l'événement dans un autre pays
thanou diallo alors on voit c'est quand
même un projet colossal comme toutes les
infrastructures autour du football pour
chaque can quelle est la particularité
de ce stade à dole
mbl très beau un très beau stade
instable de 60 mais la place qui est
située en banlieue de deux ans on dit un
bijou architectural et c'est là que la
cérémonie d'ouverture de la can aura
lieu et c'est là aussi que la finale de
la compétition se joue au niveau de la
caf est-ce qu'à chaque fois on se
préoccupe quand même de l'impact de
toutes ces infrastructures un colossal
qui sont construites dans différents
pays africains pour accueillir à cette
compétition de la can
il ya beaucoup de quand même de deux
d'experts qui dénonce des éléphants
blancs autour de toutes ces
constructions qu'est ce que vous dites à
ce niveau
à ce niveau moi personnellement je vais
beaucoup plus responsabiliser les états
et quand vous avez fait des gros
investissements paris où devait troupe
vous devez trouver les voisins moins
pour les les entretenir on a vu dans
beaucoup d'autres pays qui ont organisé
cette calme et il est les stades les
infrastructures en passant ont été
pratiquement laissé à l'abandon et ça
c'est tout moi je sais très dommage
parce que vous ne pouvez pas faire vous
pouvez pas faire un aussi gros
investissements et ses infrastructures à
l'abandon c'est pas possible donc à ce
niveau il faudrait que les états
puissent mettre en place des stratégies
pour pouvoir maintenir et entretenir ses
enfants sportifs qui ont coûté très cher
ils vont y
est ce qu'il ya des discussions entre la
caf ajustements et les pouvoirs publics
africains à ce niveau
l'on à ma connaissance en ce qui
concerne l'entretien et la maintenance
des stades n'y a pas d'excusés par
contre si vous l'avez remarqué cette
année les compétitions africaines
interclubs et les matches des
éliminatoires de la coupe du monde ne se
sont pas joués dans tous les pays parce
que tout simplement la à partir de là
partir de maintenant la caf n'acceptera
plus qu'un match de football se joue
dans n'importe quel sac si vous n'avez
pas si là et s'il est si le stade n'est
pas abonnée temps vous vous êtes vous
serez obligé de délocaliser vos matchs
il ya beaucoup de grands pays de
l'afrique de l'ouest qui ont été obligés
de jouer leurs matchs soit au maroc ou
dans l'autre pays on a vu la côte
d'ivoire allait jouer ses matches au
bénin parce que tout simplement la cua
du motion à aucun stade homologué et le
prg et le sénégal son premier match
obligés d'aller jouer ailleurs et ainsi
de suite beaucoup d'autres pays
africains ont été obligé de délocaliser
leurs anges parce que tout simplement la
caf a décidé que on ne peut plus
accepter cela on ne peut plus accepter
qu'on joue sur n'importe quelle surface
surface de jeu donc si vous ne
remplissez pas certain certains critères
vous êtes obligés d'aller jouer ailleurs
alors c'est vrai que cette can à cette
compétition un prestigieuse elle a quand
même un coup un gain sportif et
économique pour certains une folie
financière a pour d'autres écoutez ces
réactions recueillies à aucun monde la
préparation de la can se passe dans les
très bonnes conditions à mon avis
on voit les travaux qui sont faits rien
ne peut empêcher l'organisation des
matches là à la situation actuelle un
homme heureux aussi bien que les
infrastructures soient terminés avec le
nouveau présent la fécafoot nous savons
que les choses vont se passer
positivement vous allez bien voir
partout ici en libye on laissait les
nettoyer et pour que ça soit propre et
sauf que ya encore quelques points noirs
qu'on peut noter ici on va voir les
écoles par exemple qui sont vraiment
très très sale vous allez voir vous
savez les moustiques se développe
généralement là où il ya la qualité et
nous aux contres se pose la question est
ce qu on ne serait pas là encore de
préparer ou à la élevés plutôt les
moustiques manta que les étrangers qui
viennent au cameroun donc c'est le point
noir que nous avons constatée par
exemple dans notre zone la zone de libye
il faut vraiment qu'on a cherché travaux
mais quand même d'autres stades comme
celui de japoma
bépanda tous les stades sont programmées
les prêcheurs problème son niveau des
routes les rues de là vraiment la route
n'évolue pas on n'a pas arrangé les
rouleaux ne voulut pas et un taux de
cash et thanou diallo l'impact
finalement de la can sur les pays hôtes
leur économie c'est une question
récurrente quel bilan faire à ce niveau
quel bilan faire à ce niveau si déjà
vous avez vous développé des
infrastructures sportives ça c'est un
ouf développer des infrastructures
hôtelières des infrastructures
aéroportuaires et vous créez des emplois
ça c'est quelque chose dans beaucoup de
pays c'est à l'occasion de la can
on profite pour mettre en place les
infrastructures parce que à la base
peut-être que l'état n'avait pas n'avait
pas un plan pour leur mettre en place
ces infrastructures la maintenance
problème si vous faites si vous faites
ces sacrifices comme je l'aï dit tout de
suite en investissant la halle pour ces
sectes il faudrait il faudrait l'étendre
il faudrait pouvoir les entretenir parce
que imaginer aujourd'hui au cameroun
patrice moment disait tout à l'heure qui
l'ont lui stade il y à quelques là
quelques années si on regarde les matchs
de l'équipe nationale
s'était c'était un vrai scandale un
grand pays de football mais les stades
car il n'était pas du tout un bon état
aujourd'hui il au stade louis-ii stade
mans j'étais au cameroun il ya au mois
de janvier pour le chan championnat
d'afrique des nations j'ai eu l'occasion
de voir ses stats là c'est vraiment le
cameroun s'est offert des très belles
infrastructures sportives à au cameroun
maintenant de pouvoir les entretenir et
au cameroun de pouvoir utiliser ses
infrastructures pour continuer à
développer son football alors les couacs
de la can du football africain en
général est ce que c'est lié à des
problèmes de gouvernance au niveau des
instances dirigeantes
justement de défauts notamment la
confédération africaine de football on
écoute là dessus patrick baumann
dernière fois ce que je vois c'est que
la caf aujourd'hui est très exigeante et
cette exigence qu'elle demande à ses
dires collaborateurs à savoir à ses
cinquante quatre fédérations membres il
va falloir qu'elle serait mettre à elle
même est comme ça le football africain
pour aller de l'avant mais ne me faites
pas entrer dans des considérations si la
cad la caf travail bien ou pas s'il y a
des problèmes de corruption ou non
le problème de notamment de corruption
est un vrai fléau sur cette planète il
existe et on le sait sur le continent
c'est pas moi de de lutter contre ça a
moin cher incorruptibles d'abord il faut
que ça c'est pas moi de lutter contre ça
mais la vérité c'est que
j'ai surtout entendu parler de 2,2
football orfèvres est à nous d'y aller
ou la caf elle traîne quand même des
casseroles est ce qu'elles donnent le
bon exemple
c'est vrai que là l'ancienne équipe il
ya eu beaucoup d'eux il y avait beaucoup
de soupçons de corruption et de mal
gouvernance
et
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est qu'ils
sont arrivés ils veulent ils ont ils
veulent changer les choses parce que il
faut absolument changer la façon de
faire on ne peut pas continuer et si
personnellement je constate quand même
une certaine stabilité depuis le mois de
mars après depuis l'élection de gilles
d'africains patrice motsepe et parce
qu'on a vécu les avant son élection on a
vu beaucoup dans les deux sens beaucoup
d'incertitudes et beaucoup d'années où
la caf était pratiquement tous les jours
dans une zone de turbulences aujourd'hui
quand on ne gagne une certaine
instabilité on espère que c'est qu'ils
n'allaient pas la nouvelle équipe a été
de corriger cela pour pouvoir avancer au
pouvoir le
patrick baum à 10 et pour conclure que
lui c'est un incorruptible
il ya samuel eto'o qui a été nommé à la
tête de la fécafoot la fédération
camerounaise de football qui a subit
aussi une crise est ce que cette
nouvelle classe justement dirigeante va
permettre de porter haut et d'assainir
aussi le milieu du football africain
j'espère vraiment que samuel pourra
apporter quelque chose quand on est
grand on le sait tous samuel a été un
grand footballeur a reconnu dans le
monde entier maintenant ils changent
d'opposition il devient manager d'une
d'une fédération nationale et je suis
convaincu que il pourra changer les
choses au cameroun parce que quand même
de vous bronca monnaie a connu beaucoup
de beaucoup de crise il était à l'heure
je pense à leur troisième comité 2 de
normalisation si peu de temps c'est
beaucoup ça veut dire que vous n'avez
pas le temps de vous concentrer pour
pouvoir développer le football tous les
jours vous êtes là en train de régler
des crises donc vous n'avez pas le temps
de dérouler en plein développement dont
j'espère et je suis convaincu qu sa
meule et pour apporter des changements à
ce niveau là est votre pronostic thanou
diallo pour le vainqueur de cette can
ça va être une carla assez relevé
tout le monde parle du sénégal c'est
vrai que oui sur papier c'est clairement
l'équipe à l'équipe favorite l'équipe du
sénégal a beaucoup de grands joueurs
dans son effectif pratiquement tous les
pros station doubler voire même tripler
beaucoup de gros talents et il le met
les sénégalais malheureusement les
sénégalais ne sont pas satisfaits de
leur sélectionneur national donc mais je
pense que le sénégal n'a pas de voix à
l'heure et je veux mettre ma pièce
plutôt si oui sur le sénégal merci
beaucoup à vous thanou diallo on n'a pas
demandé j'ai demandé quand même à
patrick baumann son son pronostic je
pense que ça doit être le cameroun merci
à vous on salue aussi patrick baumann et
merci aux équipes du mag et techniques
pour cette émission merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis retrouvez après connecte
sur nos réseaux sociaux et notre site
arte france point tv je vous souhaite à
tous une très belle année 2022 à très
bientôt dans afrique connecte sur arte
france